nosy be ok j'ai regardé sur new yorkais
ce que c'est c'est un nom de merde déjà
c'est une sorte apparemment 2 dark souls
des temps modernes pas du tout des
samouraïs on va casser des cuves à se
faire casser le cul on sait pas mais ça
va être une première mission au quai est
là pour se garder d' accord très
pratique quand vous avez 9/10 vos
parents sont absents sur youtube comme
il a dû le regarder l'autre c'est
violent je vais couper la tête
allez viens de battre mon gars demain
elle s'auto dans 20 minutes quand y'aura
pas difficultés aux mondiaux [ __ ] ça y
est ça fait seulement 30 secondes que
j'ai dit qu'on serait dans 10 minutes
mais regardez ce que la taille de son
arme
or depuis une potion futin mais c'est
comme dans dark souls a beau être mes
gars des potions au las vegas sands du
parti va te calmer tout de suite mon
gars en ont commandé espèrent c'est
l'apocalypse
pardon pardon tranquille tranquille rpm
mais non tu déconnes jeu tout refaire
allez on n'en parle plus hop c'est légal
ok mon pote c'est l'heure de la
vengeance mon gars avec cette course de
huit mètres va
il va couler ça dégage et ma grave y
avait atteint ya combien de tours aux
sanglots halle avec adam faith et
d'autres joueurs qui sont morts pardon
j'en comprends des pauvres moi je vais à
l'instant volonté d'autres gens par
exemple le petit oif qui passe par ces
casseurs way it is nous avons bien ok
aujourd'hui nepton brésilien roberto
beaucoup aux poteaux il sort d'où lui on
a la mecque on a tellement pris la
meilleure arme du jeu pour combattre
royal un coup avec une porte excellent
os est réussi ou pas là franchement on a
fait le taf mais qu il faut arrêter ça
plus jamais un des gars je suis parti de
chez moi
ok ça vegas et là ils sont plus
lentement à tous donc du coup je vais
très très bien regarder ça donnera au
premier boss si on a un jour boîte c'est
quoi ça mais qu'est ce qui se passe
depuis qu à des zombies mais c'est un
tricheur certains schèmes tricheurs
voilà voilà sillage maniquet toute ma
vie marteau d'armes de bron c'est quoi
cette merde garder le ballon
oui quand je suis mort à civray [ __ ]
acquadro huit morts tumeur généralement
une minute après il faut que j'aille
chercher l'endroit où je suis maman je
crois que c'est juste là donc ça tombe
bien il est là pareil ça brille ça
brille de mille feux seront cadavres
j'ai touché la tombe est bon je te
récupérer
excuse moi de zombies merde je trompé
d'endroit non oh non mais je suis
content si je mens posture basse ah bah
voilà que s'attaque en bas pour la la
j'ai un pur style mec jaloux tu es une
jupe sur le zombie qui peut monter ce
nom en bermuda un bermuda pardon je me
suis enflammé tu connais bien on
continue on voit où le sauvageon et je
me casse ils sont eux on est mal on
n'est pas bien on n'est pas bien on
n'est pas bien ok ce parti c'est bien
ces moments là la carte du cul
mais bien on est bien on est bien on
temporise y en a un qui est mort le
deuxième il fera pas long feu sur tous
les plans dire en plus on est resté
serein on n'a pas paniqué c'est bien au
modjo garder lui il fait quoi le bec
ohlala le mec il a accompli de voir un
coffre en train de brûler quoi génial oh
là là on y trouve bien là et ça c'est
fantastique terre le cas ce qu'on a aimé
on est trop stylé voyez ce regard là
c'est le regard d'un homme qui va faire
mal aux défenses on dit que sa mère et
son duo avec échange d'un prêt de
changer d'arbitré une fois lens béthune
équipements ok c'est bon on a eu le
temps ah mais c'est bien là je t'attends
bien la question à faire tu sois faire
tu vas faire non
trois pilules oui il reste deux belles
gt avec 4 quoi mais c'est incroyable ok
c'est bon en mon dieu oh mec j'ai eu un
c qui double tâche et j'ai toujours
voulu avoir cette arme c'est double ça
vaut aussi chine aux mondiaux à temps
mais lui les fat mon gars il n' armure
de ouf
elle fait ton attaque seignol à gp louf
c'est bon on a eu quand il est à terre à
temps c'est faux c'est bon j'suis pas
fair play il a fait chasseurs dans la
bouche à oreille était mort butin mais
toi tu es vraiment une [ __ ] toit
aux locaux tu as cru que tu étais m'a
fait plaisir
merde bon ça c'est un petit pétard ou
bien d'un mec j'aime pas fait exprès de
tuer lui [ __ ] mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment mais que je suis désolé
pour la bouche c'est pas fait exprès oh
là là on a tout il a chaud mais on s'en
bat les couilles
en fait ce qui est fait c'est qu'il leur
cours le dessus sur internet a même au
jeu m'a pas surtout les nine note mon
père dans sa jeunesse il était
artificiel aujourd'hui on va lui rendre
hommage
c'est un sketch je veux pas mourir mais
papa fallait pas prendre ça allait
partir à dire ce qu'est la barre dans la
tête ça fait mal de penser aux le mec il
a un casque
donc maintenant j'ai compris que tu as
le dessus sur mes coups mais vu le
talent je vais défoncer vas-y raté
oppenheim à prévenir mais il fait trop
mal en fait je saigne après je suis
paralysé chiant la bombe merci un
caillou et la tp n'est pas ce que j'ai
compris c'est un coup monté un raid est
le boss mais qui va me fait vomir c'est
sûr pour moi c'est quoi ce truc
hellboy ses albums à côté des gros
bâtiments non mais qui lui restait - hp
que moi j'ai toile quoi allez allez
viens te battre mon gros là au nom et à
l'alcool en fait pas du tout va bien
c'est le boy quoi ah mais les différents
lui elle est beaucoup plus manière ils
attaquent on va alors brochet comme un
sanglier essaiera t on sans broncher
sanglier on a défoncé et là pendant
qu'il est à terre qu'est ce qu'on fait
en flic
oh mon dieu tous il ajouté el hout et
dix fois mieux que le premier temps
envisagé de faire le combo spécial
spécial c'est les soldes a en fait il
est rapide ça coupe les têtes alors
précis là-dessus sur les combines shit
est émise à lévézou
mais p mais c'est un truc de malade bon
mec
on va passer aux choses sérieuses c'est
à dire classe a7 terme d'enfants la
salle et gageons apprendre h
allez met la hache et les mille fois
n'ai-je pas quoi je m'obstine avec l'ama
violence d'enfants la question à faire
là entre ces deux murs et en bois ici
c'est mon père faire
pourquoi je meurs parce que quand même
table pour perso ce bloc
il se demande quel est le sens de la vie
à ce moment précis maintenant à nos
vêtements après monte vite au web suite
il me suit est là qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand il monte au posté de fuck effectué
grâce à tes cachets de faire taire un
oui j'ai un fusil j'ai eu un fusil il a
le gros porc on va chasser comme le
sanglier moi je voulais dire tiens je
suis mal non la musique correspond
parfaitement
moi je pense qu'un délire avec les toits
ça c'est pas la première fois elle est
là puis la howie on a traversé sa envie
de chialer
oh [ __ ] projet me casse c'est moche et
thomas chômage paniqué j'ai paniqué mais
non hélas autour du mcs à saïda plus
tard de match mais je le détestais mon
[ __ ] mais à toute la map
non il ya plus d'espacé à capter moir
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette vidéo
j'ai pas le temps de formater à kerfot
je tue le gros avant on a un coût et je
suis mort
oh [ __ ] j'ai bien que vous n'avez
mourir j'ai une solution la
manifestation enfin oui oh oui allez
vont mourir tout ce petit à petit aller
ils sont en feu ils sont en feu ils sont
un peu yes but
ok faut aller terminons cette merde on
va repasser par là je vais puiser je
suis fatigué je peux plus oui on est
passé va y avoir dénoncé une mauvaise
nouvelle
tu fait foi
tailles de 12 pouces l'antidote ue mais
utiliser il n'a pas utilisé mais quel
beau et j'avais vu une échelle c'est
pour moi jackson monte
j'étais bloqué non non je meurs tu as
prépa toute attente en regardez regardez
je sais comment on peut tous les tuer
mecque pour de vrai hockey j'ai pris une
compétence ça fait que je peux d'un coup
faire ça voyez où je veux en venir
c'est la fin ça fait une heure quarante
que je suis en train de jouer
on n'a même pas atteint [ __ ] de bosses
mais c'est quoi ce jeu alors ouais y'a
des mecs style est partout qui décapite
mai mais [ __ ] c'est dur ouais ben
jarrod cette vidéo sur oignons je vous
aura plu on s'est bien fait courir à
préparer le boy et par ses poteaux qui
viennent à 8 contre 1 n'hésitez pas à
laver ça vous a plu en tout cas moi j'ai
adoré je suis pas déçu parce que j'adore
les joues il ya beaucoup de difficultés
comme ça en solo parce qu'en multi c'est
encore plus rageant comme si tu te fais
exploser la gueule par un autre mec plus
fort que toi dans ton ordi atteint
dimanche ndlr ça va regarder partez-vous
viaggio de mambé 5 honneurs de ce mois